I feel like that we've been talking
about it talking about it talked about
and now the Super Bowls here it's time
you feel it it's like palpable here in
Miami how excited and how special is it
for it to be here it's such an amazing
place first of all the NFL is a
hundredth year yeah it's right here in
Miami I mean we can make the case it
should be in Miami every year because
this is tailor-made Miami's tailor-made
for the Super Bowl and I know Jennifer's
excited or family's excited you have two
great teams you have perfect weather
have the ocean what else can you ask for
well let me say I got a couple things I
can ask you first of all I know that
you've seen the set from start to finish
what are we in for on Sunday during
halftime I mean it's gonna be an
unbelievable show I was just in the
building two couple days ago and the
energy the magic I mean you can just
feel the importance and the magnitude of
the game but what's really great is when
you're gonna have Shakira and obviously
gonna have Jennifer and there's so many
surprises that you're gonna be blown
away by and the fact that you can only
see this on Fox and along the way
besides it's Dan Marino I'm gonna be
doing live hits from the house and from
the locker room
prepping everybody just a little instead
of what Jennifer's up to okay so you're
gonna start first thing in the morning
at home and I wish you wait you gonna
wake her up like Jen live it's me but
not live because we're gonna live should
throw me out of the house but something
like that I mean I want it I want the
fans at home to be able to capture on
our socials and on Fox all the things
that happened before the big night so we
can get like on the ride in what you got
what she's thinking what you're talking
about
there'll be a lot of surprises I think
you're right on the money or very hot
and not warm you're hot
and that's exactly some other things
we'll be we'll be doing I love that up
here she's told me before how much of a
grounding force you are for her and a
calming force especially when she's in
those moments of like the madness
so how have you been doing that for her
you know in this moment I know she's
excited but she's you know billions of
people are watching that's right that's
right you know one of the things we've
done is not over booked ourselves I mean
it's really important it's so easy to
just fill up the schedule and what
happens is you don't enjoy it we've
actually give ourselves some time to
breathe and let them sit and really
enjoy everything the Super Bowl comes
it's not just sports I mean you have
like mothers and grandmothers and little
kids everybody you'll have 150 million
people watching on Fox and she's so
proud this has been a lifelong dream for
Jennifer she's worked so hard and I
cannot wait to see it
speaking of little kids she's given us
some little hints along the way which I
like about sharing with us rehearsal
with a lot of kids around now will we
see your kids you and Jennifer's kids in
the halftime show as well I think you
have a great great info I think they're
they're are exactly what you said and
I'm gonna leave it right there because
if you keep his interview of I'm gonna
be demoted to uber driver and security
for Jennifer so I think it's gonna be
great
you've told me that your security tell
you one clue you'll see something on Fox
you've never seen before is this Alex
the big kid I mean you just got to play
with your idol I just lived out a
lifelong dream I mean with one of my
heroes Dan Marino obviously growing up
right here in Miami he got here in the
mid from Hades and he just lived this
city on fire yeah and I read once where
he said when you met him when you were a
14 year old kid your heart stopped it
did you know I was I was I was actually
stalking him because I know he had the
theory no show at the Town and Country
mall and I literally
behind a car and when I saw him walk I
got out and I made my move I came to him
with a football and I was actually 13
and he put his arm around me and I was
like your side put his arm where I'm at
he goes man you're a good-looking kid
you're gonna do big things in this world
I got to tell you I went home and I told
my mom I said mom I'm gonna do big
things
oh my hero told me I can do big things
and that damn for me has always been one
of one of the guys that I've loved so
what do you tell that 13 year old kid
then today you know it reminds me the
power that we have right and the
platform that we sit in and we can take
that power and do a lot of good with it
and just the power of words the power of
taking that extra moment and not just
signing but making the eye contact and
just a few encouraging words my goodness
it can go so long for the death for the
next generation
[Music]